[Musique]
c'est la Semaine du Goût et du coup on
va faire un petit déjeuner à l'école
donc normalement vous n'avez pas dû
déjeuner ce matin
normalement c'est une première ce petit
déjeuner tous ensemble cette année
Débora Guen a 14 élèves au lieu des 24
habituels c'est un CP
dédoublé c'est vraiment depuis qu'on a
des classes dédoublé qu'on se permet
d'avoir des des temps comme ça des
moments de partage des moments
collectifs on favorise le langage de
découvrir plein de
choses c'est la seconde année qu'éloïse
et ses copains de classe sont en petits
effectifs ici le dédoublement commence
en grande section de maternelle déjà
elle est mieux au niveau des sons bah
c'est
mieux
[Musique]
donc puis ça va mieux depuis l'année
dernière les enfants étaient en classe
dédoublé en petits effectifs et on
remarque avec mes collègues de CP
vraiment une différence dans la mesure
où ils ont eu l'habitude de travailler
en petit groupe donc ils sont ils ont
l'habitude d'aller sur les bands d'être
calme d'aller à leur place il y a c'est
beaucoup plus calme et puis aussi on est
rentré plus vite dans la phonologie on
voit qu'il y a d'énormes progrès qui ont
été faits au niveau des sons ils sont
rentrés beaucoup plus vite dans la
lecture que les autres
années ces enfants sont scolarisés dans
le quartier des fougères de grandcharmon
en zone d'éducation prioritaire c'est
pour cela que les classes de grande
section de maternelle de CP et de CE1
sont
dédoublé une mesure mise en place
progressivement en France depuis 2017
pour réduire les inégalités sociales
entre
élèves quand tout le monde est là amis
on est 12 combien d'enfants il manqu de
de de donc il y a deux enfants en moins
alors 12- 2 ça fait 10 et oui 10 c'est
très confortable parce que il y a moins
de bruit a moins de de stress on
travaille plus pour chaque enfant on
arrive à
individualiser et comprendre où dans les
acquisitions où en sont chacun on est
très proche des enfants et on est
toujours on constate un problème on est
tout de suite dans la remédiation en
fait on améliore et et on ajuste notre
enseignement à chaque enfant tout le
temps en
fait c d e f
t bravo
super pour les parents d'Alya et de sa
grande sœur Anna c'est une chance que
leurs filles bénéficient des classes à
petits effectifs à grand charmon la
carte scolaire relie le quartier des
fougères à un secteur plus
résidentiel ah tu me montres ce que tu
as fait Anna l'aîné des filles a elle
aussi été en classe dédoublé en CP et
CE1 le fait d'avoir été dans un dans un
dans une classe à effectif à 12 ça ça a
vraiment ça lui a vraiment permis en
fait de d'un peu de se libérer d'être
être un peu plus en confiance et de
pouvoir s'exprimer plus facilement parce
qu'elle nétait pas du tout comme ça donc
c'est beaucoup plus flagrant pour Anna
que pour Alya a déjà un tempérament de
base un peu un petit peu plus à l'aise
et je veux dire que l'évolution elle
elle est flagrante c'est impressionnant
positivement
j'entends au quartier des fougères il y
a beaucoup de familles en difficulté en
2022 le taux de pauvreté était de
40% c'est des familles où il y a peu de
peu de formation des un revenu médian
qui est qui est très bas beaucoup
d'habitat social aussi il y a peu de
propriétaire sur sur le quartier bonjour
il y a des beaucoup de famill
monoparentales on sait que sur le
quartier il y a plus de 30 % de familles
monoparental il y a aussi un accès à la
formation pour pour des jeunes adultes
qui est plus faible qu'ailleurs bonjour
bonjour c'est gentil de descendre du
coup on parle un peu de l'école dans le
quartier vous voyez
parleavise est l'ignant chargé de
coordonner lestion pour le réseau
d'éducation prioritaire le REP c'est
avant tout un réseau qui met en lien les
projets au collège de socho dans les
écoles et les maternelles de ce
secteur qui dit réseau dit en fait
l'importance dans l'éducation que ça
soit pas des des mesures pctuel de 6
mois d'un an parle souvent de pédagogie
dans l'école donc il y a une cohérence
entre ce qui se passe à la maternelle ce
qui se passe dans les écoles mais il
faut aussi une cohérence éducative que
les enfants ils comprennent ce qu'ils
font à l'école et qu'ils y mettent du
sens nous voilà au CP la classe des
fondamentaux savoir lire écrire et
compter
60 ok vendu allez tu l'écris en
mathématique et moi je te lesis pas
Mariam ça va pour toi pour répondre aux
questions les enfants utilisent la
méthode qui leur convient le mieux cet
enseignement différencié c'est la base
de la pédagogie dans toutes les écoles à
30 24 ou 12 élèves c'est seulement la
seconde année que David Loiseau enseigne
à un petit groupe à 24 on finit aussi
des fois sur les retes juste dire on a
on a maintenu le cadre les enfants
étaient respectueux ils étaient on les a
mis au travail là j'ai pu dépasser ce
stadelà de me dire il faut qu'ils soi
attentif je savais qu'ils étaient
attentifs et je savais qu'est-ce quels
étaient les freins qu'ils avaient pour
ne pas être attentif donc j'ai vraiment
eu ce sentiment-là j'ai eu le sentiment
aussi du coup d'être allé plus loin et
d'avoir pu permettre à des élèves dans
un groupe de 24 peut-être que il seraiit
passé pas inaperçu mais j'aurais pas pu
adapter autant et là du coup j'ai dit
non on les prend en main on se pose le
temps j'ai pu rencontrer les parents
faire les points avec eux et il y a
beaucoup de choses qui ont pu se
débloquer avec certains certains parents
qui début étent réfractaires pour
certaines aides et progressivement on
prenait le temps de le
faire cette disponibilité cette
attention accrue des enseignants c'est
ce qu'apprécient les mères de famille
que nous avons
rencontré l'enseignant voit les
difficultés qu'à mon fils parce qu'il
est en situation d'handicap il est euh
en chaise roulante il a beaucoup de
rendez-vous sur Nancy et effectivement
mon fils a beaucoup de retard et ignant
le voit directement quand ils sont
effectivement moins d'élèves et il
rattrapent son retard je veux pas dire
qu'il a tout appris plus vite mais je
trouve que les bases enfin les bases de
lecture en tout cas les bases de CPCA
sont plus consolidées c'est mieux acquis
il avait des difficultés et le
professeur il a su les détecter
rapidement et donc il a choisi un groupe
d'élèves je crois ils étaient qu ou C à
participer à ses APC donc après l'école
pour va travailler sur sur leur
manquement sur leurs points faible parce
que les enfants ils sont pas tous égau
face à l'apprentissage mais aujourd'hui
voilà il fait plus partie des élèves qui
sont en
APC à grandcharmon enseignants et
parents d'élèves tirent un bilan positif
de ces classes dédoublé une mesure
destinée à favoriser l'égalité des
chances mais est-ce vraiment le
cas pour le savoir l'éducation nationale
fait des évaluations à chaque rentrée
scolaire ce jour-là les
justement analyser les résultats de leur
école on est pour certains items assez
proche de ce qui est attendu enfin de ce
qui a été produit dans la circo hein
donc j'ai pas les résultats nationaux
encore et puis d'autres où on est un
petit peu plus
éloigné et voici le détail des résultats
en France pour deux des compétences
évaluées au début du CE1 en réseau
d'éducation prioritaire entre 2018 et
2022 il y a plus d'enfants qui
réussissent l'exercice comprendre un
texte lu seul mais quand on compare avec
les autres écoles les inégalités
sociales ne diminuent
pas même constat pour l'exercice de
calcul
mental pour tenter de réduire cet écart
d'autres actions sont mises en place
dans les réseaux d'éducation prioritaire
à la sortie de l'école des enfants ne
rentrent pas directement chez eux ils
font leurs devoirs et plein d'autres
activités grâce au contrat
d'accompagnement à la scolarité là aussi
on se rend compte de l'impact des
classes des
doublés rum à to on peut le remarquer
parce qu'on a parfois des élèves qui
sont dans la même classe mais qui aont
pas tout à fait les mêmes devoirs et
c'est vraiment important que il y a cet
accompagnement pour les enfants qui ne
rentent pas directement chez eux pour
pour ces enfants là alors oui c'est une
façon
d'établir comment dire une égalité des
chances de réussir
et de s'intéresser à l'école on essaie
de lutter contre les égalités les
inégalité sociale donc c'est en ça que
c'est utile que les enfants puissent
profiter du dispositif s'ils en ont
besoin même s'ils font partie de classes
avec des petits
effectifs depuis la mise en place des
classes dédoublé en 2017 le budget
national des réseaux d'éducation
prioritaire a augmenté de 50 % quant au
budget de l'Éducation nationale il est
aussi en constante progression en 2023
13 millions d'euros sont consacrés à la
poursuite du dédoublement des
classes ces moyens là c'est pas du gâi
c'est pas de l'argent que les gens
jettent par la f il y a ce besoin là
parce que les défis sont immenses les
besoins sont grands et l'écart avec
l'école est beaucoup beaucoup plus fort
malgré ces moyens la France ne parvient
pas à diminuer l'impact des origines
sociales sur la réussite scolaire c'est
ce que soulligne le rapport PISA une
enquête inter nationale sur les
résultats scolaires des élèves de 15
ans c'est vrai que aller jusqu'à 16
élèves partout à 16 élèves ça serait
vraiment très bien en Norvège Suède au
Québec aussi ils ont des classes à 14
élèves ils sont deux enseignants par
classe donc c'est sûr que les résultats
PISA sont nettement meilleur qu'en
France mais il y a plus de moyens
développés et moins d'élèves on demand
dans cette classe de CM2 de l'école
Janet il n'y a plus de dédoublement ils
sont 21 cette mesure s'arrête à la fin
du CE1 à la prochaine rentrée scolaire
dans les réseaux d'éducation prioritaire
en France toutes les classes de grande
section de maternelle de CP et de CE1
devrait avoir en moyenne 12 élèves
ailleurs le plafond sera toujours fixé à
enfants